okay hmm well for people who are joining
this livestream this is one of our
infinite series of meetings about
additions to orphan language we got a
couple of small topics here today and
then a big topic let's start with a
small topic okay first question is
whether we should have a function
symmetric difference um which is a set
operation right yes so this is aligned
with the Union and compliment and it's
that do we have an analog of the
symmetric difference for things like in
the computational geometry system and
things
I don't think so yet what is region
that's a region what is region
difference it's one - the other but not
the symmetric difference what is the
symmetric difference of two numbers or
is that not a meaningful thing to ask I
don't know if I'm definition for that so
in this case this would be the area that
belongs to one of the region's panda
right I don't know there's Michael here
does Michael have an opinion about this
I think it's a good thing to have okay
is the name right right to choose okay
and it
be it behaves like a union and it's
exactly this implementation in it so it
doesn't preserve or there it works with
things that with head other than list so
we implement exactly this definition I
would think so I would think so
all right that was easy okay all right
okay so this is a suggestion from a user
which I think it's a good suggestion and
it is that we have intersecting queue
and this joint queue has functions of
two arguments and the user suggested
that we could make them mark and then
they would behave basically like same
queue and unsane q2 so they will be
comparing several lists or at the same
time and this allows efficiency
improvements yeah it makes it similar to
co-prime queue and things like that
right but co-prime queue is where arcs
isn't it true of all pairs are
relatively prime which is a little
different from unsane queue which says
they're all different not correct ye-yes
so here in intersecting queue it would
be they all intersect and the junk you
they are all designed in pairs so I
think that this follows very well same
queue and I'm same queue I'm an unsaved
queue has the picture that if any - oh I
see if a right note - are like in all
possible n squared pairings correct
right they have to be already very
different mm-hmm now the only problem
with intersecting here on disjoint queue
is that we have an operator on form for
them which may kill the Vark case now
the something good
that we have and then we have contains
any and contains now which are exactly
like intersecting queue and disjoint
queue and they do have also but we don't
we don't know just we don't document the
operator form if there is one I think
that there is no document it so we're
not committed to that I we're in luck we
don't okay okay if it even works we can
try it let's try them in the report was
mentioning it but let's try right okay
works but it's an error right now so I
would say the the Vark extension is more
interesting now and then we introduce a
true difference between contains any and
intersecting queue for example mmm if
you want to use the operator form use
contains any does it the second queue
[Music]
yeah it does reference contains any and
probably in properties and relations
they are we we show yeah it's the first
first example nice but what is that oh I
see in the second queue there
oh yeah the second one exactly hmm looks
good to me good suggestions mm-hm
alright that was easy okay good let's
move on to the real real meat yeah yes
so so we are going back to around
examples and I wanted to go again
through a variety of examples check that
we agree with what we have there are
some questions run in the prototype bill
here exactly
for example it's not clear what to do
with the relative errors okay question
on the live stream that I simply don't
understand believe it is most important
to overcome a transcendent equation I
don't know whether that related to
anything we were talking about with
intersecting queue nothing I don't don't
understand the the comment um related to
something we were specifically talking
about please explain how and we make the
comment cuz I'm interested
um okay here we are in the prototype
build with various errors happening okay
let's start off with basic examples here
okay this is a magnificent function I
mean so if I take this and I simply say
squared for example oh that's so
magnificent cool okay what happens if I
say one over this magnificent now let me
try you know what I'm gonna try point 1
plus or minus 0.3 ok 1 over that so
right
I see so one over that it contains zero
within its sort of error bound now it is
not a representation of the two
mathematics of doing a probability
distribution it is a set of fixed rules
how to deal with them right you to make
sure that you're under the theme there
you can do it right fern this is
assuming linear propagation of Parros
which is also only rina reasonable when
they are small compared to so we can see
later how to do higher or their
propagation of errors and then this will
get larger but it's not asking on the
live stream by the way a very obvious
question in view of what we already
talked about which is could symmetric
difference be very interesting it would
have to be something like of how was
difference I mean it would be what it
would be as the as the always pairwise
the Union always always pairwise
complements yes I think so I think it
would have to be the goodness compliment
has a distinguished first argument I
mean that what it would be would be it
would be take all the two tuples right
take all the given let's take the ABC
case right that would be the Vicki page
has a pretty nice Oh
so there is a very old version of it
yeah and I think we would need n
complement having each element first and
then all the rest whose border do not
matter
so what this talks about enery symmetric
difference operational multiset giving
the set of sets which are an odd number
of sets that's a little weird
know that I was thinking it might be
something like that that's very much
like what exclusive-or will do yes no
FAR's will do it but in general no no
it's our exclusive okay good it's the
right thing nice article in Wikipedia
here I mean this it seems like if we're
going to implement this we might as well
implement the Henriques if there's no
ambiguity in how its defined which
doesn't look like there is well we would
have to check with the region with the
geometry team because this may end up
being like the various definitions for
polygons when they cross yes the region
version yeah there are possible choices
right so the question is whether region
symmetric difference or how that works
right okay well let's ask I mean there's
a related question of how we deal with
regions with self intersections with
boundary / boundaries that self
intersect well something that's coming
in the next version are holy polygons
after all this time so we get to do
Antarctica properly perhaps oh no we got
to do Lesotho externa
yeah it's going to be not Lesotho South
Africa
well quite yes and this is does it
really have that Tennessee with summary
no okay
all right let's let's keep going here
okay so how do you feel about the name
around are you happy with it at this
point it's the sort of thing I'm getting
I mean I'm used to it
first approximation yes but so what I
was going to say that I've noticed that
you Steven
when you refer to this function
sometimes call it about I was wondering
whether in that means that you prefer
about to our own means I don't have a
good enough memory after all the
different times that we went back and
forth on those we're going around about
yes but between those two do you have a
preference I don't I think it's going to
be a little tricky for documentation I
guess it's like these are such generic
terms that people may not just get it I
don't know well I mean the point is we
get to feed a certain number of generic
terms to mean very definite things
the reason I'm not I think I'd prefer
around to about I just think about could
mean more things than around concern
having to do with text translation this
is about some topic or something like
that I'm not sure we'll ever use that
but right it seems I mean around has
more of a sense of you know continuous
place or something then about does but
it is the case that when you talk about
numbers you say it's you're more it's
slightly more common to say the result
is about 7.2 then the result is around
7.2 although both are possible things to
say I think almost if one was to confuse
it with something else it would be with
something related to nearest and that's
not the worst of confusions at least yes
it's one in
the right you know sort of meaning
ballpark right and and we have in terms
of the input with plus/minus we we have
a glyph that we're gonna use for that
not yet but but yes we will have fun
specific right but we're not using the
the we're not using the escape
plus/minus glyph is that correct
and this yeah right now I so right now I
don't think we are using it but the plan
was to avoid changing anything ready to
plus minus my I understand I agree
because a plus minus has a different set
of meanings exactly which means we
probably need to render this glyph a
tiny bit differently exactly have we
done that yet we haven't done that no no
not yet what do we think we're gonna do
to make it different we could Center it
I don't know what what it's reasonable
to do I mean centering it would be at
least a hint could make the second
argument a little bit smaller which
would make able to get off that's a
beautiful thing to do
yes I mean let's see what that would
look like in terms of I I think that
would be beautiful but um let's see um
what is that structure well here I'm
sure I can do it with 0.1 plus k plus
minus 0.45 or some point 0 4 5 ok now
let's go in here takes
yeah that's rather that's rather
beautiful I think that's that will make
it very clear what's going on now would
we
I mean that's that's not the glyph
itself though I mean the glyph I guess
that makes the yeah that makes the whole
thing clear
I really like that idea and that then is
is you know then this case here we might
go even smaller for though maybe a point
smaller for those things um I think that
maybe should be centered so how do I do
that that is a how do you nudge is it
command C command who knows George on
the livestream is pointing out that on a
Mac plus/minus is shift option plus but
I wonder whether that's that that is our
glyph for um shift option plus okay um
and I think that's that's the current oh
great
um yeah that's the plus/minus function
but the problem with plus minus is that
it means something different
it doesn't mean around it means
potentially plus minus as in a plus
minus B plus minus C which has a
perfectly good mathematical meaning that
isn't you know that isn't this whole
thing with errors right and that's why
we we also have a minus blast that have
any meaning in ever probation yes I mean
it is a shame that it's not more readily
typable because you know the fact that
there's a shortcut for typing this it's
a shame it's a shame that that glyph
can't be um more easily typed but we've
been through this multiple times before
and I don't think we can I mean we don't
actually absolutely have to cross that
bridge right now but we need it it needs
its own glyph what do we think the
Escape key will be for that glyph for
the glyph for around
hmm Hazen knows I mean that seems like a
plus - which is kind of yucky
you see does that mean uncertainty well
that's not what we're calling around if
we listen by out by our conventions this
would be escape AR or some such other
thing which right now is not taken it
appears that array is is taken for the
things would show up in the first point
of Aries and okay well that's a boy that
I should I should have that in in the
that goes along with this wow I never
realized that we have those those fine
um wowie okay well never mind what about
the tech p.m. I don't think that helps
because I think that as soon as it's
something to do with plus/minus we're
back in the box yeah yeah I think a
Yaris is quite reasonable right
I mean you know there's a question of
how people will actually input these
things in other words you know if
they're getting them from somewhere else
like they're typing in a whole bunch of
you know results from some random you
know physics paper or something it would
be lovely if they were able to use some
keyboard shortcut for this thing I mean
of course in principle we could support
some keyboard shortcut for this we'll
have to see we'll have to see but but ok
the plus minus thing um okay let's keep
going we've got lots to discuss about
the functionality of this okay so this
is the asymmetric case beautiful
symbolic case beautiful beautiful okay
what happens
so our all operations supported here so
if I do so let me let me try an example
here so let's say I say around oh that's
an interesting point if I'm saying
um okay around random rail I don't know
-1 to 1 and then let's say they're all
point O 5 and let's say we make a table
of a 3 by 3 array of those things okay
hey this is pretty magnificent ok now
dun da da drum roll all this work that
right these speakers it's basically
considering that is considering those
things are symbolic and then all the
operations are performed by plasm times
ok so if I say something like this and
now I take that dot the original one
drum roll let's see what does this look
like so let's let's take a look I'm
perfect
that indeed looks very nice it's great I
mean I don't know the air applied such
quite interesting how the error
propagation worked um good fourth sorry
what's the question
no no Michael is saying this is being
done internally by brute force yes the
standard formula of partial derivatives
and no no I think what Steve means that
it basically made the symbolic
determinant and that the symbolic
determinant they related so this scheme
is not feasible for say
a thousand times a thousand one right
right yes we have a hope of being able
to do that well this is the sort of
thing that we would have to go into the
functions themselves like related to
automatic differentiation in the end yes
well this is the sort of thing in which
we have a say so it's a bit like it's a
bit like an array of quantities versus
or quantity array if if we have a
quantity array functions can detect it
immediately and do operations as a whole
but if they find an array of quantities
they will basically detect it too late
and the operation will be done quantity
by quantity now I think it's actually
harder because even if you would detect
it you wouldn't know how to do it well
you can also do some sort of linear
manipulation of a race if needed if we
had some sort of a rung of an array plus
the array of the uncertainties we could
do something but for determinants it's
not clear to me how to do this okay but
in case I mean you know of course what
will happen is in time people will want
really huge examples of this but at the
beginning the fact that it works at all
is really nice yes we may end up with an
around array of something yes yes
okay let's keep going here yes so these
this is an area that books on certainty
always discuss at length which is what
are the rules to decide how many digits
you have in the second in their
certainty yup and the rule we are
implementing is one taken from the
particle data booklet mm-hm and it
basically is when to change from two to
three and it's basically at 35 so if the
for example we see there in the second
in the third case at 22
so that's at 22 because it's smaller
than 35 if it was a hook what is 20 to
35 are you talking about yes the felt
example go to assert you know yeah so
you see that the error has a 22 yes so
the question is why are we showing two
digits and rather than one just yes had
two the answer is because 22 is more
than 35 so if it was a 31 we would still
show what when we threw him at 31 what
was well 31 sorry I did I'm completely
not honest yes so so the idea is we take
the two first significant digits of the
uncertainty which is which in this 22
yep and if they are larger than 35 then
we take only one so for example if we
had that the inserted he started with 47
we would round to 5 and the error will
be 0 0 5 what rule come from Y is 35 a
relevant thing yes so the idea is that
you want to round errors without losing
too much power so for example if we had
a rule of always keeping one digit we
might be converting say 14 into 10 so we
are losing like nearly 50 percent of the
other so that's not accepted and some
people follow a role of 15 which is
anything larger than 15 is one digit
below 15 is two digits
some people follow up 25 and some people
follow a rule of 35 boy I never thought
about this before okay
are we going to be able to parameterize
this in some way right now we have not
but yes I guess the question here is
whether we should whether we good
we should given the arbitrariness that
you just described we should I mean most
people will be happy with whatever we
decide is the default not least because
for example I've never thought about
this before
liselle think I have um where would we
put this in number form or what number
form what does number form do in a case
like this does number form get all and
small here I don't know whether it's
preferred to do something no I I think
right now number form is seeing this as
a symbolic object and not doing anything
but we certainly should prepare all the
number form variants to report numbers
in scientific form yes but I think I
think this is independent perhaps should
be notice not a system option but
perhaps some sort of dollar variable
somewhere
well like dollar print precision right
what happened to dollar print precision
to be renamed it no I think at the end
we only have the option oh and where is
that oh I see it's a front end option
yes it's an option it's a style sheet
option yes version to a system option
system oh yeah yep that's funky I mean
given given the fact that that isn't
even exposed it seems crazy to expose
this but probably they should both be
exposed I mean yeah this is an
interesting bizarre thing because
obviously the one that you know one of
the biggest shoes is how many digits do
we display in that case right and that
seems to me to be a
bigger more obviously big deal than this
case here I think they should both be
given some who maybe they should both be
big dollar variables I mean it also has
an option in around itself so far Iran
doesn't have options but it could have
yes I understand well what happens if
you combine a bunch of things with
different decisions about that
printability yeah I don't know and I was
thinking that perhaps our own should
have mathematical options not so much
typesetting options yes but also I think
that you know we want some local form of
this that is just like number form can
be a local way of specifying you know
within this column of this table I want
it to typeset this way right yeah um
okay so look you know yes let's figure
out how to do this we need to
parameterize this but let's keep going
right now here okay I hate the trailing
periods here I see do we really need
them well I mean not
in the fact that these are approximate
numbers it's obvious they're approximate
numbers you can't have a useful around
well I mean can you in fact have an
around what is around do if I say around
10 comma 2 for example yeah that's what
it does well but internally if you do
include forms still the exact numbers
it's not that it's numerous icing ok so
if I say squared of that okay this is
for the typesetting the typesetting
always wants these two so I mean there
are a bunch of decisions to be made with
this typesetting right and you're like
this particular I mean the very fact
that this is displaying and what happens
if I try and copy paste pieces of this
this is this is a sort of thing that is
not know it is some more color I'm
eventually when it's all decided I mean
I should so right now this is
typesetting in this floating-point form
yes the main thing here was that if you
have for example some formula for the
error it looks ugly when you have
Exponential's and squares and square
roots etcetera what does that have to do
with this I don't know I mean in this
case I would have expected to see 10
plus or minus 2 not 10-point o plus or
minus 2.0 well it's the genetic rule
that whenever no matter what you have
inside the arguments of around a they
will numerous eyes at least the error
because otherwise when you propagate
formulas you start seeing square roots
I see so in other words if I say this
hmm interesting
I mean it's fairly reasonable what
that's doing it will be kind of crazy to
have 10 plus or minus 1/2 Michael do you
have any thoughts about this I think in
many more cases there pas will be better
okay what do you think about okay fine
but what do you think about the case
this case here yeah no it's fine we just
strip it
I think we should strip it I think it
looks ugly and computer assisted the the
the other possibilities there so if you
see that's an exception to the rule of
only showed two significant digits in
the error so there we are showing for
the other thing I was thinking about is
whether those cases should factor out
something x say 100 or 10,000 this case
you mean important in scientific
notation yes
no not for a small number like that I
think it's a mistake but explain to me
the two-digit rule yeah so we were
discussing before that errors only show
up to one or two tickets this rule of 35
yeah why did this file how did this
managed to get out of that because we
would have to show 1 2 0 0 to follow
that rule and then we would kind of
converting that the 1 2 3 4 into 1 2 0 0
that's why I was thinking that perhaps
if we factor out we can keep inside
something plus minus 0.12
times 10,000 Michael what did the
standard say about this do you know I do
not know what they studied they much
more did I do me yeah I've seen that
notation multiple times in the books
which notation the notation in this case
it will be something like 1 2 3 4 5 6
sorry 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 . 6 7 plus minus
0.12 and the whole thing times 10,000
yeah I mean the point you're making is
that the after the 1/2 those digits
they're just garbage for well not
garbage but not use it for at all they
are already too too much into the air oh
yeah
gosh I don't know it'd be good to see
more examples of this yeah try to do
around that around and divide it by a
thousand some say that a thousand period
C so that looks nicer so the question is
whether to represent the original as
these one times a thousand but by the
way if I put in here one two three four
point blah blah blah I would just get
one two three four right yes so so right
now this is thrown away numbers
following the rule of thirty-five except
when they are to the left of the decimal
period then they are kept mm-hmm let's
start off this way I mean clearly if I
were to do this times 10 to the 7 yeah
that's kind of silly exactly that gets
problematic so I think this notation I
was saying to factor out the numbers
automatically this is a message coming
from decimal form because here dual
wrote
so yes sir so these internally is
working via decimal form and imposing
some position and it's the combination
of those that those zeros to their right
of the number clearly this should have
gone to scientific notation and all of
them would have been happy yeah yeah see
yes so that's what I'm saying that there
should be some automatic switch to the
to scientific for well your claim is
your claim is that potentially if there
are more than two digits to the left of
the decimal point in the error that it
should switch the to scientific notation
yes
maybe you're right I mean but times 10
to the 2 will look really weird will you
ever get that yes I guess we have the
same situation as with scientific form
we will have to have thresholds it
happens yes but as you say the threshold
as soon as you've got more than two
digits to the left of the decimal point
in the error craziness yes but it's not
too crazy it this case is really crazy
with 20 yeah right so the threshold I
mean the default threshold you should
use should be the same as we use for for
n you know for anything like this which
is you know yeah if I do this times 10
to the 20 you know I'll clearly get that
yeah so that threshold you should use
yeah the question of whether you go all
the way down and never have more than
two digits to the left decimal point in
the error is not clear to me it would be
nice to look at examples in the
literature I mean did you look like in
the particle data table what do they do
what I see in most cases is this
scientific form factorized yeah I'm
looking here I can't believe I've been
subscribing to these books while they
may have stopped sending them to me but
I started getting them in 1972 um a lot
more is known about particle since that
time okay what I'm seeing here is a
bunch of things where there are two
digit precision let's look at some boy I
mean it just so happens that a bunch of
these things are you know it's
interesting so they've got in some cases
they even used three rarely but some
cases they they they are so proud of
what they measure that they want to use
three yes
um is there a master discussion anywhere
in this book or elsewhere about um I
mean I mean there's also the whole
notation of digits and then the last few
digits and brands maybe you're going to
talk about that in a moment
yes further down we discussed that or
having them in gray smaller surfacing
okay let's take a look at those so I
don't have a great example of this right
now
um okay let's keep going here
um okay yes yes yes that's what we just
discussed exactly
Avogadro's number okay that's what we're
talking about this well how would you
input avocados number I mean is this
around I thought this was 6.0 2 3 that's
what I remember has that changed in the
last 50 years so much okay so my memory
is just not that's a problem with my
memory not with that's not with the
constant okay um okay so so how would we
input this and why would it output like
this rather than times 10 you know plus
minus it's not necessarily that it would
automatically output like that it's more
like how do we offer the possibilities
of outputting like that well notice that
to not output like that what you would
be outputting is 6.022 blah blah blah
blah blah plus/minus 0.000000 which is
quite ugly yes yes
so I mean if we're gonna do this we
should use the same convention of making
it smaller that we do for these other
ones but what does this mean now exactly
it means the uncertainty in the last
corresponding digits also in the 57 what
yes so so you have to imagine that these
74 corresponds to the positions of the
57 so it's zero point as many zeros
until we get until zero eight and then
74 so over it this means we've got this
number of things this would be plus
minus zero zero zero zero zero seven
four where the 74 aligns with the
position of the five seven is that
correct all right so the question so
it's a graphic-design question can we
invent so I mean clearly if this is
what's going on we've got to tag the 57
as being the uncertain digits yes I
think we need a device here that's
that's something so I mean how would we
do this what would be a unified way so
normally this would otherwise be around
let's put in that number 6.022 one four
zero eight five seven comma point zero
zero zero yeah
for serious more and then solidify
and now why did it cut off that last
because 74 is larger than 35 oh boy this
is a subtle business that's standard me
everybody agree that if you never seen
for example our rule of 45 no no I
understand why did have a gathers number
get a 74 there even though that last
digit even though the seven and the four
at the very end of garbage in a sense
it's not garbage it's it's a matter of
how important statistically this will be
and yes this may seem a decision of
whoever writes it okay but but this so
what we are proposing what we need is a
notation that can involve smaller digits
and this isn't decoration and so on that
kind of merges these two ideas yes
because essentially what happened is
this 57 here I mean really what we would
like to be able to do if I were to you
know kind of indicate it would be
something like and we can't do this as
such but something like this that's kind
of what we really are talking about here
because once you reach above hundred
comes a little bit strange because you
have to go one to the left the eight
gets changed
well no no I know but I'm saying the
five seven is uncertain than the
uncertainty in the five seven is plus
minus four seven
yeah okay so the point that I'm making
is that that's
conceptually the fact that the
five-seven is on I mean it is super
embarrassing that I didn't immediately
know that I think Michael has explained
it to me before what this means
it's what coated I used since at least
20 years I know I know I know I've seen
it many times but I've never actually
needed those digits enough to actually
care about what this you know what that
means
and you know I view that as a bad sign
in terms of you know if we serve a
typical people who don't you know cuz
nobody uses those digits of avocados
number realistically for you know unless
you're doing metrology or something um
right so I mean embarrassed to say that
I thought that that 74 was was that was
the part that was uncertain not that it
was the uncertainty of 57 um but in any
case so I mean the thing that it almost
feels like okay so let me try one
example of a way we could do this and
maybe it's you know let's imagine that
we could do something like this where
these are in the past we discussed grain
out the last oh yeah tell me what about
oops
no now I'm making this now I have to
make that bigger to think that I don't
like that it gives you the feeling the
eight is in all cases correct Richard
isn't what do you mean why isn't it
correct because 57 plus 47 flips to a to
a nine I think that's I mean look if we
really wanted to be unbelievably cute
see about it we'd make the eight
slightly smaller
immediately I mean this look that
notation is at least clear I mean I for
example wouldn't be confused by this but
I understand that the eight isn't but I
mean nothing is certain like in these
things here where you say plus minus
you're stating digits and then you're
saying oh whoops actually they might not
be correct all right what happens if the
decimal point is between the five and
seven
arrghh
you mean the error is like in the first
case in your screen right now which we
have one point two yeah I understand so
I see so the problem is if there are a
lot I mean none of this is relevant
unless there are lots of digits you're
not going to want to do this unless you
have how many digits to the left I see
because you have a the left you just
want to do you know like three digits to
the left you swim to plus minus this is
really a story of codata metrology you
know all that kind of stuff now you know
we could decide that for the time being
we're going to punt on those precision
measurement things and just do it this
way make the precision measurement the
people be proud of how many 0s they've
managed to get in there look I think
this is the direction we should be going
for this something like this but let's
keep going a little bit here we've kind
of running out of time but let me just
for your amusement I will put something
in the chat
we are up to date with the things
oh my gosh is this what we've got yeah
you see her to uncertainty change over
time I know this is quite interesting
did it go down
always no up and down it's complicated
generically obvious down but there are
nonlinearities monotonic okay
truly complicated okay all right but
listen I I I like an approach like this
so you think you know what I would like
to try to figure out is how to merge
that you know what the boundary looks
like between the pure plus minus the
pure full number plus minus and this
type of approach and you know clearly
we're gonna have to parameterize this
with some kind of number form or a round
form or something do we have an around
form yet not yet because this would be a
reasonable set of things to parameterize
in there so we want a subscript anything
I don't think that's that's not the
right approach I think we want a plus
minus to be in there somewhere but I
take your point about what happens if
there's a decimal in the middle it's a
pretty weird case and we could force
that to not be the case by going to
scientific notation because you're never
going to be in this situation unless
you've got a lot of digits right yeah so
it's a matter of these seven official I
think so oh we talked about in the round
form okay we have straight no that seems
like the right way to do it
parentheses none automatic whatever
sounds reasonable to me oh boy you've
got lots of stuff here okay um let me
just understand what we're doing with
respect to the next meeting which
actually also is intended to be live
streamed um I would like to go on with
this is Eric here yes could we could we
move the next meeting or is that going
to be a horror to another day or a
different time um I think we probably
should move it to another day like okay
um okay from and to intervals yes I
agree that's a good that's a good thing
to do we talked about that before that
seems right yep so it just goes
symmetrically into the interval I just
felt the right thing yeah okay yes
distribution this is a bit more
difficult but in a sense all these
around are like a form of a statistical
distribution yes
so is that I mean when when people quote
1 plus or minus point 2 they think of
that quote in the 1 Sigma yes okay what
do you mean if not otherwise stated if
they say 1 plus or minus 2 at 90%
confidence level or something yes yep
but so in principle then the surround
conversion could ask for a confidence
interval
yes so the idea which I haven't
implemented yet is to have an option
here which is a confidence level option
and then you there you can say what's
the actual okay so then the question is
if you have a confidence level option
for a round doesn't that if you were
carrying that around so to speak and
around then would you expect ok so let's
say I said 1 plus or minus 0.2 90
percent confidence level yep right are
you implying that then I would always be
meaning 90 percent
evidence level and then what happens if
you try and combine a 90% confidence
level with a 50% you know 68 percent
confidence level so the idea here is
that the uncertainty in the second
argument is 1 Sigma if you say that you
have a confidence level of 2 Sigma or 3
Sigma then you are changing the meaning
of that second argument but in a sense
the statistical distribution is still
the same it says that you are describing
it a different way yeah I understand but
so what yeah ok it would matter in the
moment say you try to get probabilities
out of it yeah so do we have any ability
to convert from around to a distribution
not right now so arguably normal
distribution of around should convert
you know if you say normal distribution
of one argument around it should turn it
into a normal distribution with a mean
and standard deviation that's not
obvious because you might mean that
you're not certain about the mean of a
normal distribution Brian I see a sign
as opposed to okay so right someone
live stream is asking about the
non-symmetric case we are covering in
around if you ask about something
different let us know but but in around
well actually let's do an example that
I'm here I mean we should be covering if
we say around - - let's say oh I can't
have a negative number that actually I
want to ask about that in a minute
disables positive point two point seven
for example that will do that now let me
ask a question since since that came up
I mean it's kind of crazy and this
should probably just be an error that is
weird it's not prepared 200 yeah it
should be analytic or taking their did
they absolute value all floating you
think what do you mean by flippin
basically make the left part the right
at the right left but in this case in
which there is the only one yeah what
about the symmetric error case where the
error is negative just doesn't make any
sense I think yeah I think we just take
it absolute value yeah with a message or
without without I think you do
are you sure I mean so if I negate this
thing right so the negation knows that
it hasn't it shouldn't touch there
uncertainty that's why it is preserving
it by the way this if I do this and I
say square and so on oh that's so
magnificent right and then I do square
root of that sorry something is very
wrong no it should go back to something
yeah obviously right okay but first bug
we found in this function on say I think
in this session um okay let's go back
here so the question is if you give a
normal distribution a
as there as its mean your point is that
that should mean an error in the mean
not I mean no I'm not saying it truth
but I'm saying there's some ambiguity
well I don't think there's ambiguity in
the if you do this case here without a
second argument I don't think there's
any ambiguity I mean what's the default
Sigma in a.m.
oh it just refuses interesting we should
ask Roger in the statistics team about
this I think it will be somewhat useful
to be able to get distributions out from
around even though you know obviously
it's kind of nonsense at some level in
the in the sense that we can't guarantee
it which genuinely will be a Gaussian
distribution or anything like that now
in the chi-squared I know is that a chi
chi distribution whatever that's just
the mean and standard deviation of the
other distribution that correct what
happens if it's a distribution without
bounded variance right I was thinking
that around can always take a
distribution and and return some
approximation to it some some sort of
normal approximation but in the other
direction only the normal distribution
knows what to do with something wrong
yes yes yes I agree I think it's
hopeless otherwise right so so so
perhaps it's not worth well the other
possibility would be to have a thing
called around the distribution this may
be crazy to not force it into normal
distribution that's crazy because
because basically the point is the only
thing you can reasonably get is a normal
distribution yes well there is a slight
distinction so around can take a third
and fourth argument with the third and
fourth moment that's all it takes
because sometimes it's used but which is
what a multi normal cannot be
represented as a multi normal
distribution not a multi normal this is
one dimensional
so so it's still one-dimensional okay so
so that's my idea of an around
distribution is not completely crazy
no but the system a forgotten the name
the system has I mean in from language
we have a distribution which can take
those four parameters it has a name for
north or yes but I've forgotten okay but
so that's a reasonable thing okay so
there is a notion of Raman around to a
distribution yes I think we need to ask
the statistics folk if I don't know if
can could Eric see if Roger is around
maybe he would have an immediate opinion
about this or not Roger
perhaps um let's see if they're around
we'll ask Roger okay um yeah I'll be
right back I mean well okay so we
function expanding the distribution to a
given order what earth is this
oh well what happens if you say mean of
an around does it do something
reasonable should it do something
reasonable not right now it how do you
get the center value of an around we
don't have extractors yet right now
because it's not at all make it to be
just if the first argument do we think
mean of anorak okay so if i take a bunch
of around and I say mean of all the
arounds I mean arguably a single mean
should extract the first I mean so what
are we going to call those extractors
right so we've got to have an extract oh
here we go so you're talking about so I
mean one possibility is if we have in a
round of 1 plus or minus point
the question is what's the mean of that
and does that make any sense to be the
extractor I mean in other words we could
imagine that we have mean and standard
deviation be the extractors or does that
promise something beyond what is
reasonable to deliver what else will be
call those extractors mmm
around centre and around deviation maybe
does anybody know by the way where I'm
storing these things is there a section
uncertainty folder okay okay okay so
you're proposing something like a round
Center I don't really like that very
much that sounds very very geometrical
and by the way you know in the case of
an asymmetric thing here what on earth
do we do I mean you know a round center
around I mean that there are different
things we could say around range around
which could be the complete range around
air or I hate that air or just sounds
wrong well this does not represent us a
range this does represent they did the
distribution yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
don't get the wrong one
um okay so
we need these extractors but I don't
know what they should be called at least
I assume you need yeah I mean we
ultimately we need these extractors I
don't think it's reasonable to it's like
you know in a rational number you could
in principle say first but but you
really maybe you can't even now um but
you know you really want numerator what
these have an official name and the
literature the you know the center and
the uncertainty today well they
uncertainty it's called uncertainty but
what does the uncertainty mean does it
mean the point - or does it mean the
point for sorry you they were breaking
up no I'm saying does the uncertainty
mean the point - or the complete range
point for no I think it's its point -
it's the Sigma we just call it a
certainty yeah so it's a Peterson
distribution I was looking through their
distribution the Pearson distribution
can handle these four parameters I was
talking about okay so there it has all
these numbers there there is a some
formula to convert but it's this object
what the heck is that
first thing type that's really weird
yeah I think the types are numbers and
there are like seven different types
which probably old clothes yes and wrote
down one day and he put it on this piece
of paper one two three four five and now
we're right now it's stuck with that oh
great okay we are talking about errors
numbers with uncertainty hey you guys
can explain what it is just I'll be back
in just one second yes so we're talking
about the round and the extension to
support more moments than just the first
one and then I was mentioning that
around currently can support also
skewness
and kurtosis and that similar to what
this distribution does the Pearson
distribution which somehow these numbers
correspond to the first four moments and
yes in Stephen wanted some sort of
comments or a confirmation of them
because he was wondering whether Iran
should have its own distribution
function some sort of our own
distribution which represents what Iran
is doing for two arguments is is the
normal distribution with more it would
be a normal plant kurtosis or a normal
class courtesy skewness right so so if
you take a distribution with only three
moments and the rest of zeros all other
moments yeah assuming some condition
that makes the whole thing convert and
that sort of thing I think this is
Pearson distribution I think I actually
read that Pearson created this
distribution precisely to understand the
meaning of the first four moments so
what did we figure out I was explaining
osya the relation between around or on
distributions from this Pearson
distribution potentially mm-hmm but so
the issue is you know with around look
around is a linear approximation to
error propagation although I don't
understand this certain fourth moment so
they are they going beyond the linear
approximation well more than linear so
there's here two things one is the
distribution we start with which rather
than being symmetric it's a bit
asymmetric because we are the skewness
and kurtosis and then the propagation is
the formulas we used to transfer
the distribution which in the sister in
the statistical framework there is this
transform distribution which will do we
will do the exact thing we use linear or
quadratic or cubic approximation I think
I have formulas up to level 4
after 34 and that that's the role of our
round replace a round replace we'll know
to which order do you want to do the
preparation okay so there are examples
for the round but these are two
independent things the distribution you
use which is good either you use normal
or something that has more moments up to
4 and they say order of differentiation
during the preparation okay someone on
the livestream by the way is asking
shouldn't it just work if you replace
every year around normal distribution um
well actually it's not clear I mean from
an efficiency point of view absolutely
not um from the point of view of yeah
it's ok what is the what is the
statement on that so I think the answer
is no because for example you can add
two around but you cannot add two
distributions and so the distribution is
it plays a role of something symbolic
that used in the statistical framework
in a very definite sense around is
something else that represents
effectively the same thing but it's used
in a very different well let me just
understand something so so if I say
around ok so here's an interesting case
if I say around one okay plus around one
common point - yeah what would that do
for two distributions if I have two
normal distributions what if you do two
times around one
point that's a difference independence
exactly how is your red magic working
yeah yeah yeah right right now if I had
two distributions do we have a mechanism
in the statistics framework in the
probability distribution framework to
add two independent distributions yes
transform distribution is so if I were
to say what is it I say like this in at
least yes both x and y are normal
distributions with in this case I would
say mean one standard deviation point -
no no because x and y have to be
assigned independently some distribution
yeah
so X distributed as normal comma Y
distributed is normal okay now I see
otherwise I mean some vector distributed
somewhere which is right very different
okay fascinating not good it gives the
same answer okay will it always give the
same answer so if I were to do this if I
were to say small yes yes and under
linear and the formulas are linear right
so then there's going to be some
difference there and the point is
exported to that why didn't it do that
there are zero chance to get a closed
form for this sodding triple integral
right it may operate with you know
finding the properties on this but it
just doesn't have the closed form which
would be dead you know the head defining
the in the system do we have a single
function mean standard deviation No
okay but so the round of this thing
should arguably be okay so if I say mean
of line 45 it's gonna grind for a long
time really even the numerical articles
can't be done mm-hmm is it gauche I do
you agree it's kind of a return on a
whether I should here I don't know okay
yeah this is probably now there is
possibility of integrating again because
it has the Machine precision so this is
the sort of situation in which Iran will
do some linear approximation and get
something George on the live stream is
pointing I wouldn't wanna use around in
case with some knowledge of error but
the error distribution is not know
absolutely it's in the in the usual
sloppy way that it's done in empirical
science
wait you absolutely have no idea that
it's a precisely a normal distribution
but you have some sense that the error
is you know 1 plus minus 0.2 um yep know
completely that there are yeah this is
this is kind of error propagation the
way error propagation is typically done
in the empirical sciences and what we're
now talking about is the interface
between that and very precise error
handling and distributions which we want
to make as reasonable as possible but we
know perfectly well that we can't it's
not going to be precise so ok so let's
go back here so the question was there
two questions how do we you know what is
the interface between we were talking
about whether a round can be an argument
to normal distribution whether for
example we could say normal distribution
of around to get a normal distribution
which has the mean and standard
deviation corresponding to the
parameters of around and potentially see
I think we're gonna need something else
I think we're gonna need something which
is a you know an approximating
distribution based on around which will
turn into one of these Pearson
distributions with all of its fancy
moments if the around has more because
because I mean even this case I have no
idea what the asymmetric I mean what
distribution is that what should that
turn into so the way this is done this I
haven't written much literature about
this and there is no agreement so the
way this is typically handled is by
considering that you have two normal
distributions one with point two one
with point three and then manipulating
them separately there is a rider told me
about this way of having a distribution
which is some some sort of merging of
two distributions one on one side
another that splice distribution right
exactly glued them together okay so what
do you think kosher what what do you
think we should do here in terms of I
mean it seems to me we need a function
that we'll just do with a variety of
possibly different method option could
we not just use probability distribution
as a one art what is probability
distribution it's the interface to
defined arbitrary distribution of women
bye bye any you know function PDF so the
probability density or CDF potentially
and we need to decide what your what
your density is right which we decide
based on what kind of internal power
middle Cervantes right so your proposal
Michael is the property distribution
around I mean this seems kind of nice
sounding of a round point two would be
that particular one would turn into
normal distribution or it might turn
into empirical distribution I probably
it will be most civilized for it to turn
into zz2 okay
go show what do you think of this do you
object to that I mean if you want around
to follow normal
no no they did defense what's inside
around there might be higher moment in
their world right so for example this
case here one would have to make a
decision in that case and that would
probably have to be a method option to
probability distribution at case when we
have to make a decision what to do with
this my question also would be would you
allow infinite moments in around you're
out of the game if if you say look if
you okay so here's an interesting
question okay let me let me give an
interesting case all right what about
this case point 1 comma infinity are we
supporting that well type sets but the
formulas will collapse at some point so
when you say Gosha infinite moments you
mean an infinite number of them or
infinite values values so this case here
doesn't seem completely stupid to me
around point 1 comma infinity that means
it can't be it's not likely to be less
than 0.9 but you don't really have an
upper bound well but you see in
practical applications the jurors are
always assumed small it's the basis of
all this so writing infinities it goes
against that
okay what about but but on the other
side going to zero I mean aren't there
cases okay in the particle physics
business for example there are things
where I think where there are parameters
there's certainly parameters where you
don't know it could be just absolutely
zero it could but again these perils do
not represent ranges I mean there
shouldn't be a way of limiting this is
just an estimation of what the error is
so that's why serial infinity don't seem
correct here okay well then we should
specifically disallow this an error out
think so but okay but let's take so the
answer gotcha to your question about
unbounded variants and so on is now
right so they're normal it's the usual
way to go yes right but but in this case
where it's asymmetric errors we've got
to decide what to do in that case
and then the next case is if there are
higher moments specified that we've got
to have a distribution which has higher
moments and that's because some people
do it so if a standard it but I've never
seen more than four so the first
vertical doses mm-hmm and that's what
it's supported here because for speed
I have heard widely formulas and these
are complicated these formulas are
serious formulas that become very
complicated when you increase them
they're okay but I think look bottom
line this seems like a sensible way to
go I mean frankly this is to quote you
know it's kind of a a it's like four
diamonds quote about random ovaries I
mean this is sort of a state of sin type
thing to convert and around to an actual
official probability distribution is you
know it's kind of silly um but it's also
will be particularly I mean there will
be cases where it's interesting to do
that even though you're kind of deluding
yourself because you don't really have
that amount of information I mean I
think this is I think maybe useful fine
I find it like informative okay fine
well let's plan to do it and what are
the functions do we have to support from
the statistics framework with around
probably a bunch of stuff ultimately
like for example you know a normal
distribution with an around parameter is
a whole different story
probability might be one of the first
ones I I wouldn't go too far there it's
very slippery road but probability
seemed pretty natural like you have a
round and you want to know what are the
chances that my real they us between
doesn't
yes that's how you go deeply into the
state of sin situation right but I think
because you can compute the probability
distribution you first do that and then
you are in full statistics mode and
continue right I don't think we should
try to support I think you know anything
like that people are going to quote you
know they're going to think they're
gonna get p-values out of the thing and
all kinds of crazy stuff and it doesn't
make any sense no I mean they'll get
stupid answers with p-values anyway and
the literature is full of stupid
p-values but let's not contribute to
even more of those okay so the only
other question here that related to this
is whether mean should do something on
around on around itself I think it's a
sensible thing for it to do although is
it inconsistent you know if I were to
generate a bunch of around say I think I
had some up here someplace
right and then do mean okay so I have a
bunch of arounds here clearly wherever I
was down here clearly I want the mean Oh
blah well so much for that
okay never mind okay let's make it that
makes them around here
okay now if I say mean of that
magnificent right right so mean of a
number doesn't work right
I believe that's correct yeah so so
probably mean of our friend around she
don't work for the same reason well but
mean of a probability distribution does
work yes so it's not the case that mean
doesn't have any why oh oh yeah okay so
that's why I think mean of about should
work of around should work and I made my
same mistake with about and around just
then I think it should work I think
means should work I think standard
deviation should work now the next
question is but it mean would it really
always turn the first argument well
that's my question what if you have to
list in in the secondary image okay so
your your case is a round of 1 comma
point two point three you're asking
consistent what we do with the
distribution right so that's why I think
the idea of having extractor that
extracts the one is a good one but me I
will prefer people to have to ask for
the probability distribution and then
the mean of that yeah okay okay so
that's the volume of the round otherwise
they will ask for around to be supported
as a distribution in other places and
it's going to be a slippery road yeah
yeah someone on the livestream is
talking about T distributions and saying
there should be intelligent distribution
assumptions about what distribution and
empirical around corresponds to yeah I
mean it's kind of what we're talking
about is the the the minimal case is
supposed to be a normal distribution I
mean we would get if I'm remembering my
statistics correctly we would start
getting T distributions if we put I in
the normal distribution if we had some
parameter H I don't even know how that
what is the distribution you get if you
have a normal normally distributed mean
in a normal distribution isn't that well
I don't remember what that is
no matter um okay but in any case yeah I
mean look by default I think what we
should do is probability distribution
should by default you should decide what
this should be by default but we should
have a method option which decides that
it could be something different here
right and I don't know what distribution
you know okay so all right so we've
killed the idea of mean operating or
directly on around which is fine so now
what are we going to call the extractor
that extracts the center value it's not
is it the center value sum necessarily
the center as you point out in this case
it's not the center it's the volume
could be the value though we had
discussed in the past having an around
value that is able to extract multiple
things only the me know a bit like a
date value well that's not like a good
thing to me so a round value but would
by default extract just the the main
value right and then yeah why not
and then we can because I don't think
this is going to be a particularly
common case to ask for the uncertainty I
think this is going to be a common case
because I think it's going to be like I
don't care that these things have
uncertainty I'm just going to barrel
ahead assuming that it's the main value
so I think that's the right approach so
a round value with a second like date
value record idea okay um all right
let's continue here so what is around
expand that's that's something we had
considered in the past but related to
this idea also of expanding the round
into some distribution that's an order
but yeah it seems kind of crazy to me it
seems like we're putting too much
precision into something which is you
know where there's never really going to
be precision right I have a question
though what is the way if I've got a
table of numbers and I want to get from
okay yeah yeah there's an obvious
question okay so I've got a table of
numbers and I've you know let's say I've
got you know random real between you
know 0.8 0.9 okay and I've got 20
numbers okay and now I want to turn that
into an around you see what I'm saying
so I've got a bunch of experimental
measurements and I want to turn them
into and around how do I do it well
probably we need some of the fitting
functions to do that right now it would
be a round of the mean commodity ation
of that right but to me it seems like we
should have a function that because that
is the case right is that you've got a
bunch of I don't think there's any other
case how do you get an around you know
you have a bunch of measurements and you
want to figure out what the you know you
assume you know now in the case of okay
so how would I get a normal distribution
out of this but what do I get the what's
the estimators are exactly is
so we'll take the mean and the standard
deviation of the of the how do I
actually get it what's what's the
function estimated distribution you put
this data in so just random real and
then come on normal distribution a comma
B why do I need the a B need to put the
parameters and it's also symmetric to
the you don't need the a B over there
it's just normal distribution and to be
when you when you ask for find started
with find distribution parameters and
then we would return the rules for the
parameters okay and some distributions
take more than just you know one set of
parameters may have more so then you
know which signature we're looking at
okay
but how does it know I mean with this
support a pattern here as well it's just
very weird to have those hanging you
know symbolic variables there excuse me
yes every II in vacuum on it yep um okay
but but don't you think we need a
function Michael this is I mean D it
seems to me it
we need a convenient function that
doesn't involve going through
distributions here to go from this to an
about okay question is is turn around up
there you know I'm yes yes no absolutely
I mean from this we really want to be
able to take this thing and we want to
say what is the right term for it I mean
if we would have your earlier mentioned
mean standard deviation we could just
chain them yes we'd say no we couldn't
no it couldn't because because mean
standard deviation would return a list
oh then we need play but if we would we
want mean variance or mean standard
deviation which is the right thing with
yeah it's mu plus minus Sigma right yeah
I think it's not that's a very long
ponderous thing I mean that seems like a
somewhat useful function you know thing
to have but in the familiar three
influence yes right okay but but let's
talk about the around case because I
mean this is clearly useful thing to
have take a empirical data and figure
out what the approximation is round
approximation I hate that
what are analogous functions so we're
taking well another possible name would
be mean around which because it's
a it's taking a mean but it's giving me
a round version of the mean instead of
just the mean itself and so just the
number that's absolute silence I don't
think that's crazy that that name it's
doesn't sound right to me okay well what
would you I mean what about no probably
not like to around and then it would eat
lists and distributions I just think
that's really weird
I do agree it's a business because I
mean it there's a computation usually
the two functions are very structural
and no we cannot have a round of Phi
maybe you can have a beautiful round
this is one of the situations in which
sometimes we are the second argument to
specify the type so mean come around
could return that mean doesn't mean
already have a second argument no it
does not I'm not a huge fan of that
someone on the livestream be champ on
the livestreams to just list around yeah
unfortunately the problem of that is it
yeah I mean there's a certain argument
that lists by the time you have list
plot it's making a plot from a list but
I have a feeling most people if they see
that will think somehow a list is going
to come out but then we would need also
a different one for distribution so if
you have expertise list yes also suggest
on the live stream empirical mean I
think but I think empirical mean all
that means or empirical means and sense
yes I mean operates on the data it's
okay so the the the claim here is we
want something where around can either
be applied to a list or I mean but we've
we said previously that around on a
distribution well okay there's a there's
a much more basic question um around on
a distribution can just go ahead and
just do its thing if you just give the
it but now what happens so right now if
I say around four five six one two yes
okay there's an obvious question why
doesn't we why don't we just make it be
around itself
well the current implementation circuit
boards a vector in the first argument
with a matrix of correlations in the
second one you don't give a second
argument what if what if okay so the
what if around maybe this is a bad idea
but and it's making me you know what if
what happens is in this case for example
this says I've got all these things I'm
going to form a single number but I'm
going to assume that all these that's
kind of there seems like they're a case
that you want this normally you want to
infer the MU enter Sigma from the data
yeah I agree
right but that's the case where I
God you know is it crazy I think it's
crazy to have this turn into a single
around I don't think it's the right idea
no and I think we need something more
general because sometimes you want for
example the deviation with its error
because there is a notion of the error
of the estimated deviation so we don't
only need something returning the mean
with a deviation we need other things of
the they try the way while you were away
I kept on saying about yeah I've noticed
that that's why that's why I said it's
at the beginning that you typically go
to what other people find out saying I'm
used now to around and I find it a bit
more space meaning no no no I know what
what about the other functions here like
like plot around or something like there
what are we calling the the what are we
calling the plots that have or we not
even know we don't need to have those
it's just that they're supporting us
applause right they have options with
names like ever bars and things of that
yeah okay so listen we taught a function
to name here for taking this list for
taking what is it really doing it it's
estimating gosh what about their fitting
the fitting functions you should also
think in the case of the multivariate
case where we do have say a set of
vectors and we want to infer form this
correlations right exactly
I see so you're saying the case where
every one of these is a to vector for
example right and also how do you
represent the vector of values so it's a
single round already I have to put
around vector of rounds no no you can
have an around so I'm completely wrong
this idea of mine here is just wrong
okay the so this case here we need to
yeah
Michaels is right we have to we have to
deduce also the correlation matrix we
need something like data but these are
some sort of estimators with uncertainty
so each thing estimated will come with
its uncertainty see around estimate
anything with estimate we've got all
kinds of other estimated this than the
others you know if we want say if a
round value wasn't allocated something
else which I think it's better allocated
to that will be another possible thing
here we could feed data in the first
argument of a wrong value and then
depending on what we have in the second
argument that seems unbelievably hacky I
mean on the one hand a round value would
take a part on around and on the other
one it would create an around that seems
very hacky I mean it's you know some
conservation some name conservation
thing I don't believe in that
let's see what's another example what
would be a synonym for C I keep on going
back to a round estimate or you can say
find around around redefine that fully
deterministic
but I think we are putting too much
emphasis in the around here so the
emphasis should be in the operation
performed and then something inside
should say and I want my results with
uncertainty so how would we compute all
these numbers without their round right
now well you know that's why I like me
around but meaning is only for me what
happens if I want the deviation as an
around
so because the deviation also has an
error and what about the covariances
with an error well okay so that's that
you're making an argument for your thing
about the second argument of mean being
around but I'm worried that we might
need it also in in standard deviation
and other things that may be too
problematic so perhaps we need a
function that says I want to estimate
things about this data and I have to
specify what I won't estimate well so
that that would be you might be
proposing there something about estimate
around an accommodator
where by default alphas mean or
something yeah perhaps but it could be
also standard deviation or covariance or
something does that make sense I mean
that the okay so yeah right so this is
the interface between data and yeah I
mean that's it's like apply around or
something all this sorry we have all
these fitting functions so when we have
the correlation factors and things like
that those are things that could be
returned with estimated errors from the
fitting functions right so we have data
we want to feed a linear function yeah I
mean there's all kinds of places where
we can return this mean a lot of machine
learning functions could return these
right exactly so that's why I think that
perhaps
we need some way of specifying give me
the results with errors rather than
introducing new functions I'm skeptical
because I think that the you know if the
first argument to estimate around or
something is some arbitrary long program
you know without some sort of automatic
differentiation game or something it's
very hard to see how we would possibly
do this yes
whereas you know this case is is by far
the most common case that is I've got a
bunch of empirical data and I want to
know you know I want the it's the only a
version of dimension of accuse well
that's a very weird way to think about a
bit yeah okay so we've got a function we
need to name here um I have to want to
external you okay and I also need to go
the yeah George on the live stream is
agreeing with us that it's not going to
work to have to overload mean and things
all right we've got quite a bit more to
go through here I mean this is at least
another hour
um I would think I don't even know what
some of this stuff is so these are
examples taken from the gun
documentation just to show that this
functionality will ever solve those
examples okay let's let's let's schedule
another hour on this stuff and we know
we and let's invite Gosha to the next
iteration of this um and somebody on the
live stream actually asked about rods of
errors and there they are but um we need
to go through these right ok this is
really wonderful functionality this is
very exciting stuff we've been waiting
for this I've been waiting for this for
30 years SMP used to have a error
numbers with errors mechanism um and but
it's been gone for 30 years so um great
stuff okay thank you to everybody on the
livestream bunch of interesting comments
today
appreciate it and talk to you all soon